[Musique]
fait connaître par cette chanson et
d'autres dans les années 90 tonton david
était la vedette du heat parade
il a connu environ dix ans de gloire
dans toute la france
il avait également signé un autre titre
en référence au passé de la réunion et
c'est un peuple qui a beaucoup souffert
le sommet c'est d'un peuple qui le
peuplent ce mouvement aux opérateurs
prise de vue et réalisateur à rfo
bernard delord dollar et patrick nirlo
ont gardé une photo souvenir avec tonton
david cette photo c'est à l'époque qu'on
a envie de l'émission qui était en
direct sur rfo sap le fil rouge présenté
par jean philippe stellaire et ce jour
là on a reçu ton temps david et on avait
fait faux comme souvent le faisait on
faisait des photos souvenirs les
artistes ont sévi sur le plaque et
patrick nirlo se souvient également que
le papa de tonton david gray rabon
employés de la poste et musicien de bal
jouer du séga et qu'il habitait avec sa
famille dans la rue nicole de la serve à
saint denis une rue où aujourd'hui il
est moins de 30 ans ne semble pas
connaître l'artiste disparu
tonton david vous connaissez non se
connaît pas j'ai entendu parler mais je
connais pas je pense que j'ai entendu
quand j'étais petit mais ça me dit rien
ne vient de plus je l' ai connu à
travers les médias à travers la télé
j'ai entendu ses chansons mais je ne
savais pas qu'il était déjà originaire
de lille et surtout qui les habitait
dans le quartier j'ai oublié les paroles
les oublis de paroles mais je m'en
souviens très bien de lui avec sa
coiffure tout ça on entendait beaucoup
sa chanson
car j'en suis sûr qu'on me prend pour
des cons mais j'en suis certain
et là où tonton david aurait vécu tout
bébé avant que sa famille ne déménage en
métropole la plaque de la rue porte
aujourd'hui comme une pensée